Predictive modeling is a process of modeling
historical data for predicting future events.
For example, we want to use electronic health
record that we have available to view a model of
heart failure. So that we can predict patients who
are at risk of developing heart failure sooner.
Predictive modeling is not a single
algorithm, but a computational pipeline
that involves multiple steps. The key
goal we want to answer in this lesson is
how do we develop a good predictive model
using electronic health record quickly.
First, we decide the prediction target, for
example, whether a patient will develop heart
failure in the next few years. Second, we
construct the cohort of relevant patients
for the study. Third, we define all the
potentially relevant features for the study.
Fourth, we select which features are
actually relevant for predicting the target.
Fifth, we compute the predictive model, and
sixth, we evaluate the predictive model.
Then we iterate this process several times
until we are satisfied with the resulting model.
Prediction Target
There are often many targets that an
investigator wants to predict using the data they
have. However, only a subset of them are possible.
So, we should choose the prediction target
that addresses the primary question that is
both interesting to the investigator and
possible to be answered using the data.
In this lecture, let’s focus on
predicting the onset of heart failure,
which is an interesting and
potentially possible target.
Motivations for Early Detection
If we want to develop a predictive model for
heart failure, what are the motivations for early
detection of heart failure? First, heart failure
is a complex disease. There is no widely accepted
characterization and definition of heart failure.
Probably because the complexity of the
syndrome. It has many potential ideologies,
diverse clinical features, and numerous clinical
subsets. If we can detect heart failure earlier,
we can potentially reduce the cost of
hospitalization associated with heart failure.
We can also potentially introduce new
early intervention to try to slow down
the progression of heart failure, improve
the quality of life, and reduce mortality.
In the long term we can improve existing
clinical guidelines for heart failure prevention.